[Música]
los californianos participan hasta ahora
en un referendo en el que decidirán si
apartan o no del cargo al gobernador
gavin newsom por su manejo de la
pandemia de kobe 19 el funcionario ha
criticado a los sectores en republicanos
promotores de la consulta y denuncia un
supuesto fraude electoral en estos
comicios
fue destituido de su cargo el fiscal
general de haití que acusó al primer
ministro ariel en por el supuesto
asesinato del presidente joven el mois
el funcionario había presentado
anteriormente como evidencia un registro
de llamadas ocurridas atrás el asesinato
entre enric y varios funcionarios
sospechosos de participar en el
magnicidio un nuevo fiscal ya fue
nombrado
y en mexico fue presentada una
iniciativa ciudadana que busca
proporcionar datos relacionados con los
casos de las numerosas fosas
clandestinas que han aparecido en ese
país la plataforma permitirá a los
familiares de las víctimas conocer
detalles y avances de las
investigaciones por parte de las
autoridades mexicanos tenemos los
detalles en minutos
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález comenzamos en eeuu los
ciudadanos del estado de california en
el oeste del país fueron a las urnas
para participar en un referendo en el
que decidirán se apartan del cargo al
gobernador gavin newsom sólo tres años
después de su elección newsom es
criticado por la bancada republicana y
por diferentes sectores de la sociedad
debido a las medidas que ha impuesto
para hacer frente a la pandemia de kobe
19 en ese estado como entre ellas por
ejemplo el confinamiento el cierre de
las escuelas el cierre de los negocios y
la obligatoriedad en el uso de las
mascarillas a esto se suma otros temas
que son endémicos de ese estado como la
migración el presidente joe biden y
también la bancada demócrata han apoyado
al gobernador para que permanezca en el
cargo de otra parte el ex presidente de
donald trump denunció que hubo
manipulación en los colegios electorales
en california durante el anterior
proceso electoral a nivel federal
y esto del fraude electoral es una
tontería es una vergüenza y es
vergonzoso lo digo y lo digo como
estadounidense estoy avergonzado me está
repulsión maduren esta gente está
literalmente vandalizando nuestra
democracia y nuestra confianza en
nuestras instituciones me importa
demasiado esta nación me importa
demasiado este país estamos debatiendo
la democracia en américa ahora mismo
esta gran mentira esta insurrección que
le pasa a esta gente maduren por segundo
día consecutivo el secretario de estado
de eeuu anthony blinken rindió cuentas
ante el congreso en donde dio detalles
sobre la decisión y también el
procedimiento de la retirada de las
tropas de afganistán en la jornada de
hoy el jefe de la diplomacia
estadounidense hizo frente a las
críticas provenientes de distintos
sectores políticos de su país y también
de la comunidad internacional en torno a
cómo fue realizado el repliegue militar
y también a cómo fue manejada la
evacuación de los colaboradores afganos
de ciudadanos estadounidenses y también
del propio personal diplomático de eeuu
destacado en la ciudad de cable
y vamos a seguir hablando de afganistán
las mujeres afganas particularmente las
que están viviendo en el exilio utilizan
las redes sociales para difundir
fotografías de la ropa tradicional
afgana y también subrayar la riqueza y
la diversidad de la cultura de ese país
veamos
un mar de telas negras frente a una
universidad de kabul este fin de semana
a la cual las redes sociales
respondieron con una ola de colores
rebeldes este tuit de la académica
afgana bajar yalal y desencadenó el
movimiento aparece con un vestido suelto
verde y rojo y con este breve comentario
llevo un vestido tradicional afgano esta
es la cultura afgana desde entonces el
hashtag ha sido ampliamente difundido
para cambiar la imagen de la mujer en
burka negro
no quiero que el mundo piense que esto
es lo que somos que esta es nuestra
cultura que de alguna manera esto
representa a afganistán conozco el poder
de los medios de comunicación el poder
que pueden tener las imágenes en todo el
mundo así que publique una foto mía con
la vestimenta tradicional afgana y pido
a las otras mujeres afganas de todo el
mundo que hagan lo mismo porque las
imágenes hablan y matthew turner
los talibanes anunciaron que las mujeres
podrán estudiar pero separadas de los
hombres y tendrán también que llevar un
velo completo
estas coloridas imágenes representan una
resistencia contra las estrictas normas
de los nuevos líderes del país
afganistán es de ley drivers marcan
organizar es un país muy diverso con más
de 14 grupos étnicos y todos tenemos
nuestra propia vestimenta tradicional
station clouds y ninguna de ellas es lo
que los talibanes quieren imponernos
like esta protesta en línea no se
refiere únicamente a la ropa de las
mujeres la cultura afgana es también
arte poesía y música tantas prácticas
prohibidas total o parcialmente por los
talibanes
el personal sanitario francés también
los trabajadores de residencias de
ancianos y otros profesionales que
trabajan con personas que son
vulnerables tienen hasta este miércoles
para vacunarse contra el kobe 19 si no
lo hacen podrán volver no podrán volver
a trabajar y no cobrarán sus salarios
esto en francia aunque la proporción de
trabajadores de estas profesiones no
vacunados es muy baja sin embargo es
significativa este marte los sindicatos
y también los profesionales de la salud
en ese país europeo volvieron a
protestar en las calles
y
le esperaban que el plazo no llegara
nunca este miércoles los profesionales
de la salud que no se hayan vacunado
contra el cubil 19 serán suspendidos la
decisión pretende frenar la enfermedad y
evitar que los hospitales se saturen
pero los sindicatos y muchos
trabajadores dicen que la vacunación no
debería ser obligatoria
como profesionales de la salud sabemos
cómo tratar y proteger a nuestros
pacientes pero desde hace un tiempo
intentan hacernos sentir culpables
cuando durante la primera oleada nos
trataron como dioses
wason y sueñan con sus google 300.000
trabajadores sanitarios perderán su
sustento sentimos que nos están
sacrificando y que a nadie le importa la
misión general los hospitales de parís
dicen que la proporción de profesionales
no vacunados es pequeña aún así si ya no
pueden ir a trabajar esto supondría una
mayor presión para los hospitales que
carecen de personal el personal
profesional o estamos hablando de
100.000 trabajadores del hospital y ya
hay recortes por todas partes se
imaginan perder otras 100.000 personas
entre las principales razones por las
que algunos no quieren vacunarse están
el miedo a los efectos secundarios y la
sospecha de que las vacunas no sean lo
suficientemente
eficaces de paso hemos tenido pacientes
totalmente vacunados que tuvieron que
ser hospitalizados en unidades de
cuidados intensivos esos porque estaban
contaminados con la variante de
la gran mayoría de los trabajadores de
la salud están vacunados incluso varios
escépticos lo hicieron ya que no podían
prescindir de su sueldo lo que no está
claro es si los que aún no recibieron
dosis o podrán regresar a los hospitales
dentro de unas semanas
volvemos al continente americano fue
destituido de su cargo el fiscal general
de haití que acusó al primer ministro de
ese país de ese país ariel en que por el
supuesto asesinato del presidente
juvenil moix el funcionario destituido
había presentado previamente como
argumento para la acusación un registro
de llamadas telefónicas realizadas sólo
horas después de ocurrido el magnicidio
en dichas llamadas se oye conversando
con funcionarios que son también
sospechosos de este asesinato del
mandatario ya un nuevo fiscal fue
nombrado por las autoridades en ese
cargo
y se cumple un mes del terremoto de 7.2
grados que sacudió precisamente haití el
movimiento dejó más de 2.200 personas
fallecidas 12.000 heridos y cerca de 130
mil viviendas destruidas las
organizaciones como naciones unidas y
también sus socios humanitarios siguen
prestando ayuda a esta nación caribeña
pero en sus esfuerzos de respuesta
siguen siendo desafiados por las
limitaciones que presenta este país como
por ejemplo el difícil acceso a las
zonas afectadas por el daño en las vías
y también la delincuencia
el 14 de agosto de 2021 un terremoto de
magnitud 7.2 dejó haití de rodillas más
de 2.200 muertos
137 mil hogares destruidos y 500 mil
afectados
los niños lloran porque necesitan comida
y agua estamos buscando por todas partes
pero sin conseguir nada valioso
según la oficina de la onu para la
coordinación de asuntos humanitarios más
de 650 mil haitianos necesitan ayuda
humanitaria de emergencia del cual
apenas el 46 por ciento la recibió hasta
ahora y para llegar a todos los
damnificados la organización estima
necesitar más de 187 mil millones de
dólares pero hacer llegar los
suministros a los más necesitados no es
fácil la devastación del terremoto se
vio agravada por la depresión tropical
grave que provocó dos días después
inundaciones derrumbes dificultando aún
más el acceso a las zonas más remotas
especialmente en la provincia muy
afectada
aunque la comunidad humanitaria se
congratula de los esfuerzos de todas las
partes por llegar a las zonas más
afectadas este acceso tendrá que
mantenerse a largo plazo sobre todo si
se tiene en cuenta la falta de medios
aéreos y marítimos disponibles para
llegar a las personas afectadas tras las
sucesivas catástrofes que han sufrido
año tras año al dejar en efecto padre y
rápida' las autoridades haitianas y sus
socios internacionales han prometido un
mejor manejo de la ayuda humanitaria
para evitar que se repita la historia de
2010 pero la unicef denuncia que más de
medio millón de niños carecen de refugio
y no tienen acceso a agua potable o
higiene abriendo la puerta a posibles
enfermedades como el cólera o la malaria
según esa misma organización más de 700
escuelas resultaron destruidas por el
terremoto una nueva calamidad que se
esfuma a dos años en los que los niños
se han visto privados de escuela debido
a la inseguridad la inestabilidad
política y por supuesto la pandemia de
kobe 19
pasamos ahora hasta méxico en este país
fue presentado una iniciativa ciudadana
que busca esclarecer interrogantes
relacionados a los casos de las fosas
clandestinas que han aparecido a lo
largo y ancho del territorio de la
república mexicana vamos a conocer más
detalles con jorge ruiz él es integrante
del programa de derechos humanos de la
universidad iberoamericana en ciudad de
méxico y es también integrante del
equipo investigador de esta plataforma
bienvenido señor ruiz gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en france 24 y
comienzo por preguntarle por el inicio
de toda esta historia en qué consiste
entonces esta plataforma qué tipo de
información va a proporcionar y cómo se
alimenta esta plataforma
hola santiago muchas gracias por la
invitación al espacio así pues la
plataforma ciudadana de fosas es un
esfuerzo que en realidad venimos
haciendo diferentes organizaciones y
academia méxico desde el año 2015 lo que
hemos hecho es sistematizar la
información de fosas clandestinas que
vienen de fuentes oficiales y nueve
oficiales por ejemplo fiscalías o
procuradurías estatales de los 32
estados del país la fiscalía general de
la república y también la prensa escrita
nacional y local el objetivo es reunir
la mayor cantidad de información sobre
fosas clandestinas para poder tener un
diagnóstico sobre la magnitud del
fenómeno no entonces pues a lo largo de
los años hemos
publicado diferentes productos de
investigación sin embargo ahora
decidimos hacer esta plataforma
interactividad que pueda ser accesible
al público y que se pueda consultar de
diferentes formas no les las las
personas pueden consultar cuántas fosas
clandestinas se han localizado por
ejemplo por parte de la prensa o también
comparar con las cifras oficiales y pues
los datos también están abiertos para su
descarga para que las personas también
puedan por ejemplo auditar los o
utilizarlos para otras investigaciones
señor ruiz esta plataforma es una
respuesta en cierta manera a la
impunidad que hay en méxico o en torno a
varios casos que están todavía sin
esclarecer también a la lentitud de las
investigaciones por parte de las
autoridades oa quien responde sí
correcto el objetivo principal es
contrarrestar un poco al vacío de
información que hay por parte de las
autoridades sobre todo hay que recordar
que en mexico en 2018 entró en vigor la
ley general en materia de desaparición
forzada y desaparición cometida por
particulares esta ley crea por ejemplo
muchos buenos instituciones y programas
de política pública y también
herramientas de información dentro de
estas herramientas se contempla por
ejemplo la creación de un registro
nacional de fosas clandestinas y postes
comunes que tendría que ser llevado por
las autoridades para justo e integrar
toda esta información y que se pueda
utilizar por ejemplo para generar
investigaciones y también posibles
programas de búsqueda el problema es que
pues ya a tres años de la implementación
de la ley general pues también no
contamos con este registro nacional de
fosas clandestinas por parte de las
autoridades no después el objetivo de la
plataforma es poder contrarrestar un
poco esto y puedes poner a la
disposición esta información para las
propias autoridades para colectivos de
familiares en búsqueda y para la
sociedad en general para conocer la
magnitud del fenómeno lo que también
estos datos usarse por ejemplo para
programas de búsqueda y exhumación en
mexico importante iniciativa señor ruiz
muchas gracias por explicarnos en
detalle esta iniciativa y muchos éxitos
con ella allí en mexico vamos a cambiar
de tema siete personas cinco de ellas
integrantes de una misma familia de un
reconocido empresario brasileño
fallecieron al estrellarse el avión en
el que viajaban el aviones de pequeño
porte se precipitó a tierra sólo 15
segundos después de despegar de un
aeropuerto de un suburbio en la ciudad
de sao paulo
esto en las noticias muy buenas noches
[Música]